on the radio interviews I did at least
90 percent of the first 25 of them would
always start with the same thing Zig
they tell me you could sell anything to
anybody I said you know they lied to you
when they said that because you've just
described a con artist no legitimate
professional salesperson would ever
dream of selling anything that he did
not fervently believe was in the best
interest of the person he was selling to
of all of the qualities of a good
salesperson must have number one is
integrity see we are trained as
salespeople to persuade other people to
buy to make decisions and an unethical
salesperson can persuade people to buy
things that they don't need are
overpriced are they pressure in them
into buying it a legitimate integrity
driven and sales person will only sell a
product that will enable him to sell
them again and again and again a product
he would sell to his mother that's the
kind of salesperson who has long term
valid success and poise and a lot of
people stand in front of the stove of
life and they say now stove you give me
some heat and I'll put some wood in you
that ain't the way it works you got to
put something in before you can get
anything out so many times you know the
employee goes to the employer and say
give me a raise then I'll start coming
to work on time alright so many times
they will come to Evans they make me the
boss now I know I haven't been here very
long don't really deserve to be the boss
but I just function better when I am in
charge of things you reward me now and
then I promise you I'll learn what this
business is all about later on reward me
now and I'll produce later doesn't work
that way you gotta put something in
before you can expect to get anything
out isn't it true that anything worth
doing is worth doing poorly until you
can learn to do it well we'll never know
how many kids have missed a college
scholarship because they didn't study an
average of ten more minutes a day this
is a story of success this is a story of
life I believe with all of my heart
if you would pump long enough and hard
enough and enthusiastically enough that
a big another reward is going to follow
the effort you just watch - amazing
clips from Zig Ziglar take the next
three minutes to sit quietly and think
about how you can apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]